hey guys i'm ryan right Samantha Ashley
bells samantha is finally back on the
channel it's been a very long time she
was getting into the wrong industry for
a while no no no you could cash for
videos Fergal website Oh leave him
please do not search that we're gonna
check out the trailer today for
masterminds official trailer number one
Kristen Wiig's Zach Galifianakis dream
team coming together ha dream team
coming together just hit play my name is
david gans I always felt I was destined
for a life of adventure they didn't
quite pan out that way until I met miss
kelly campbell would you do with a
million dollars of a star own business
maybe be a bounty hunter nice know that
bullet just went straight between your
cheeks yeah feels like it just dries my
biscuits rather ha
it tells me all work together over at
loomis that strikes me as an incredible
opportunity you talk about robbing a
bike how long can it be you load up a
truck can you drive away at least I'll
calling it one of the largest ever
robbed a bank this man disguise how many
for you keep your teen down to
seventy-eight cents looks like if jesus
incant had a baby I know you're just too
good man doing a difficult
from the cut David damp from teen we
can't do this this is wrong so y'all
woman he killed whoa not in front of
he's one of them no boys go upstairs
right now she all a little bit
David can't is here to revenge
I stay I guess you just met me Oh what
are you gonna say
press release
no way out
the presents just don't show up who
you're a Christmas tree i mean i'd like
to see these turkeys go out and earn 17
million dollars mean-spirited comedy
indeed i wonder how much of that is
actually true was this actually a story
that was kind of funny or did they just
take a true story and turn it into a
comedy I mean it could have been either
it looks pretty funny no matter what but
you know I do need to know things like
this to see how funny it really is you
know like based off truth hold on i'm
gonna go murder that family outside for
making too much noise you're distracting
me they're distracting me too how dare
they I haven't murdered a family in a
long time I mean you've gone this long
why why start again Veronica's be
variants that to have to bail yeah yeah
you can just get bailed out from her
grave Amelie this is an awesome cast
okay like it's produced by one of the
dudes who produced um we're the millers
ah totally had that field a really funny
and like kind of mean-spirited kind of
comedy yes I do enjoy a good
mean-spirited kind of filming one
character that I'm actually drawn to is
Owen Wilson because Owen Wilson is
someone who is normally like the
laid-back nice dude and you know it's
like he can be kind of a cocky dick
sometimes but Heath he's going for a
much more mean-spirited kind of humor in
this yeah and I'm interested in seeing
will Owen Wilson's like more dark kind
of comedy he looks like a genuine
jackass in this yeah like it sleazy
jackass I know paralyzer myself Wow have
you seen almost and says well are you
guys seeing that video why what Owen
Wilson says well like in almost every
single movie he does he doesn't like
that Wow and Kristen Wiig is amazing
just I think always she's hilarious she
looks pretty hot she does look really
hot has she been working out um well she
was already thin and then it leads to
good looking in Hollywood but like she
looked especially hot but no had the
lollipop moment
yeah I like seen that lollipop go and
Kristen Wiig's mouth I know I'm sure
yeah most guys did yeah and zach
galifianakis hairy ass [ __ ] he
is awesome I really do enjoy watching
him in films he's one of those comedians
whose just not afraid to really go all
out and commit to the bits like when he
was laughing he was really turning red
in the face doing that he just goes all
out like he goes balls to the wall balls
to the wall balls deep balls to the
mouth whatever you want to say about
balls that's what Zach Alf knock is this
gorgeous balls to the wall I'm just
saying he make me want to murder that
family and one thing about this film
that I'm seeing a lot of his slapstick
and the slapstick looks like it's pulled
off well like good physical comedies
more jicama Kanakis is such a slapstick
comedian but like you know he just
commits to it and he creates honesty in
that and I think that's what makes it
hilarious so you're not stupid slapstick
it ends up being pretty actually funny
in my opinion well you said that point
really well thank you I'm proud of you
thank you very much anyway guys thanks
for tuning in to the real rejects if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to this awesome YouTube
channel this Empire you can subscribe to
it and you can check out Samantha
Channel please do cuz you know if you
think he's cool yeah there's this thing
we should talk about with Samantha on
the channel many months ago it's about
people defecating on her chest no not
okay we're not bringing that back I
think we should bring it back I thought
we moved on from this I think Facebook
post and do we add don't do it that'd be
fun it was up and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and vine
where if we get enough followers that we
can get more product placement that's
right Samantha I've already gotten some
product placement now I want to make
more money money is the root of all
happiness was just don't add to it come
on round money yes it is if money money
solves so many problems children don't
listen to him
is not happiness okay it will take you
too bad i can give you an example of
everything right now i could hire
someone a hitman to [ __ ] take care of
that family for us if i had more money
hence you can go to jail for that though
hence more product placement I need more
product placement to afford the money to
get hit man well why are we product
placing something out i want a product
play something he can't just product
plate something second money you gotta
get them an offer to you what if I
product place this glass doesn't even
know what kind of glass that is it is a
very cool glass see this is why I mean
this is why we don't make money this is
why we don't make money well you know
what I'm trying it was trier you're
drinking my water he drank my water
sorry I was really in the moment hmm
welcome to the uncomfortable